Uh,
[inaudible]
phonemes and allophones.
These are terms we use to make sense
of the way sounds work in a language.
Take just two sounds.
N and M to test of speakers here.
These two sounds is two phonemes.
We see if we can find words
where switching one sound
for the other gives us a
completely different word.
Here's the word meet.
Switching the M two and
n gives us the word neat.
This is a minimal pair. The two words
different minimally by one sound only,
but what's the point of this? Well, by
holding all the other variables constant,
we can see if switching the sounds in
question changes the meaning of the word
is switching one sound for another
changes the meaning it follows that we're
looking at two different words and
if they're two different words,
English speakers treat the two sounds
in question as different sounds in this
example and an m are contrasted and this
contrast tells us that and [inaudible]
are two distinct phone names in English.
A phoneme can have different
pronunciations. Take this sound.
K he comes up with a puff
of air in the word kite,
but not in the word sky.
These two sounds and are different,
but we hear them as
variants of the same sound.
We call these and
allophones of the phoneme k.
The same goes for mm
and in the word input.
I have heard that word pronounce both
input and input making mm and variants of
the same sound. Ella
phones of the phony and
the sounds and show up
in different places.
After s we hear only skyscan skirt,
but at the beginning of a
word we hear can keep cool.
These elephants show up in different
environments where we find one we won't
find the other and vice versa.
That kind of mutually exclusive
relationship is called complimentary
distribution.
Other elephants sounds can show
up in the same environment.
Go back to the word input.
Input varies with input in a
tomato, tomato sort of way.
These two allophones of the phoneme n
are in free variation with one another.
This last example shows you that one
sound like [inaudible] might show up as
allophones of multiple phonemes.
Hm is how people usually
pronounce the phoneme m,
but it's also how some people pronounce
the phoneme n in the word input.
In the next lesson,
I'll build on the concepts
of phony Minallah phone and
begin working through the
pronunciation system of a
foreign language. As we do that,
I'll help you uncover all
the basics of phonology
[inaudible].